Hello, and thank you for being here. I'm
Roberto, and today I'm going to tell you
this song of types and agents.
Uh basically a song that speaks about
languages that fight each other to
conquer what's the throne in the AI
realm. And how I think that TypeScript
might actually be winning this war.
But let's start from the beginning.
A few years ago, whenever someone was
building uh in AI,
they were certainly using Python. Like
there was no doubt.
All the other languages were bowing to
Python because
um
because of its dominion uh over the AI
world.
And then, when in 2022 ChatGPT was
released, everybody started wondering
and starting understanding
that AI was becoming something more. Was
going outside of the bubble that lived
for years.
And started to becoming something more
ambitious. And together with it, Python,
which was the standard language for AI,
became more ambitious as well.
And that's how in 2024
uh GitHub actually claim claimed the
ladder and became the most popular
language on GitHub.
So,
you know, everybody was happy. Python
finally reached the top.
But little did they know that
there was another contender for the
throne. Another contender that was
rising to challenge the claim that
Python had on the throne.
And this contender, as you may have
guessed by now,
was indeed TypeScript.
But, before talking about this, let me
present myself. My name is Roberto. I'm
the CTO and co-founder of Reto, a
context layer for AI agents.
And I'm also the EU ambassador for AI's
Pratic, a global community of AI
builders meeting once per month to
discuss the latest news in AI.
I'm also a long-time JavaScript then
turned TypeScript developer. And that's
basically
why I am
talking about TypeScript today.
So, let's
begin.
As we said, AI started moving up to the
stack. It was moving from the
infrastructure layer of these
models, machine learning, and all
related ecosystem towards the
application layer.
This means that AI
stopped being something that you train,
and it started being something that you
ship inside your application.
Applications started featuring AI,
starting having features powered by AI.
Which basically means that we started
having applications that think.
And the application layer
was not Python's.
The application layer has been
TypeScript's for pretty long time now.
Don't get me wrong, like I still think
that Python has its own
application. Like I still think that the
brain of the of the agent and all the of
all the AI world is actually still owned
by Python. All the training, the
research, the GPU serving is all
Python's. Uh Has been Python's all along
and it's going to be Python's for long
time yet.
And
um what's changing is actually the
application layer. Like
few years ago, if you wanted to build
something with AI built in the
application, you had to use Python.
But today, that's not the case anymore.
And that's all
uh the shift is about.
TypeScript doesn't just own, you know,
the UI or the back end. Started owning
also the agentic layer of our
application.
And that's why in August 2025,
TypeScript TypeScript actually passed
Python as the most used language on
GitHub.
And the funny thing is that the reason
that the GitHub reports gave
was the same. Like in 2024, it said AI
leads Python to the top language. While
in 2025, it said AI leads TypeScript as
the first language.
And in both cases, as you can see, the
global developers, the number of global
developers were surging. In 2020 2025,
we even have one new developer joining
GitHub every second.
So,
what actually changed in this year?
Like
yeah, we were flooded from like new
developers. In 2024, these newcomers
were reaching for Python, or even maybe
existing developers were reaching for
Python.
And in 2025, they reached for TypeScript
instead.
What changed between 2024 and 2025 was
actually
coding agents.
The coding agents grew up like we saw
established
um
we saw the players establishing
themselves like Lava
Cloud Code, Cursor, Codex. They became
the default way to build applications.
And the default way to
uh to which these coding agents actually
built the applications was TypeScript.
And
you know
since
every new app pretty much every new app
is an agent today because they ship
these AI and agentic capabilities, they
are hungry to embed AI inside
themselves.
The demand to have more AI integrations,
more and more AI integrations
doesn't fall on through Python.
>> [clears throat]
>> It falls on TypeScript.
And pretty much all the tools that we
use to build AI today already run on
TypeScript.
We
even saw
an AI lab acquiring a JavaScript runtime
like last December Anthropic acquired
Bun.
But still, you know, okay, everybody use
is using TypeScript because of the
coding agents and we are having
more and more demand to build uh AI to
embed AI inside TypeScript
application.
But does this mean that we should do it?
Like this is a fair question, like it's
an honest question
and it's a question worth answering.
And the answer in my opinion can be yes
like for several reasons.
The first one is that since TypeScript
is the default language for coding
agents today, we can expect that they
will become better and better in in
TypeScript because we are having more
and more application in TypeScript,
which are going to field
the training of next coding agents.
And then we are having
uh deeper integrations and more native
integrations from these coding agents
towards TypeScript, and we can expect
that the quality of the output in
TypeScript is going to be better and
better from these coding agents. Since
we're building applications,
and uh we want to have like the highest
quality of these applications,
might make sense to build agents, which
are the new kind of applications in
TypeScript.
And also,
if you use TypeScript, you are actually
tapping into what is probably the
richest package manager out there.
NPM comes with everything, uh pretty
much everything, like authentication,
payments, UI, infra. Like it's uh the
deepest up layer tail that there is.
So,
since again, AI is coming towards the
application layer, we need to integrate
with all these right now. And tapping
inside NPM is a very convenient way to
do that.
Also, you have
by building in TypeScript, you can have
one single language throughout all your
code base. You can have one single code
base for the whole application.
Because you can use TypeScript for your
agent loop, for the tools, for the back
end service, for the UI.
While if you use Python, you probably
have to split uh split it at least into
two services.
Which means, you know, one service with
FastAPI, Pydantic AI, and whatever.
And then
another
um separate React application that you
need to sync between between these two
with a uh with a contract, which you
have to maintain and synchronize.
And speaking of contracts,
with TypeScript, you can have one single
consistent typing across all your all
your application.
While if you use Python instead, you at
some point will stop at a boundary, cuz
you will have your agent, maybe your
back end, etc. with one consistent
typing, and then you will have your
React application or Vue or whatever
with um another set of typing at which
you need to synchronize between the two.
So, if you use TypeScript, you can use
Zod as a single schema throughout all
your application, which is very
convenient. You can define a type once.
You can use this type in the back end
and uh in the model, and you can use the
same type in your UI.
One type, checked and went.
Also, like
it makes sense to build in TypeScript
today uh also in the AI ecosystem
because we are seeing a very surge in
in the AI ecosystem as well. Like take
the Versatile AI SDK, for example, you
can see that in just 1 year, it went
from 1.6 million to 15.1 million
downloads per week, which is between 9
and 10x in just 1 year.
So, finally, I'd to put everything
together. In my opinion, yes, it makes
sense to build AI agents in TypeScript
because you have like a
uh you can leverage the
the de facto default language for coding
agent. You can have one single language
for your whole application and your
whole code base.
You can tap into uh fast-growing AI
ecosystem.
You can have consistent typing uh across
all your application. And you can tap
into the richest package manager that
there is, NPM.
So, um
you might ask
was all this unpredictable? And the
answer is actually no. Someone predicted
this uh many years ago, almost 20 years
ago.
Jeff Atwood said, "Any application that
can be written in JavaScript will
eventually be written in JavaScript."
And you know, as you as you probably
know in the last few years, we have a
corollary of this that any application
that could be written in JavaScript will
eventually be written in TypeScript.
And so basically, we can say that any
application, even the gigantic ones,
will be written in TypeScript.
And be mindful that what I showed you
today is just the beginning. Like, we
are just getting started.
You can project this in a few years and
you can see that on the application
layer, the difference between TypeScript
and Python is actually going to widen
from here.
So,
um
as I said, the model can still run on
pip.
But the agents, which is the application
layer today,
so the agent that called the models
will probably ship on NPM.
So, everything on the inference layer,
you know, it's going to be Python.
But everything but else,
probably all TypeScript.
Let me leave you with one recommendation
then.
Um
keep training in Python. As I said, I
don't see that's one going away soon.
But please consider building the agents
and the applications in TypeScript.
Because if you don't do that now, if you
overlook TypeScript,
you are probably going to fall behind.
That was all on my side today.
I thank you all for your listening. And
please scan the QR code for the slides.
Reach out to me if you agree or if you
disagree, if you have any feedback, and
let's get in touch. Thank you.
Bye-bye.